good 2018 be the Year Britain loses its
cool by autumn the complex for exit
negotiations should be drawing to a
close
Deal or No Deal what's decided will
affect the future of Britain and the
continent for decades to come is the
Contra point for the for the Praxis
cause this will be the point at which
people start to know that some deal is
going to be reached as brexit begins to
bite not only is Britain's economic
future in play but the country could
lose its street cred it really feared
that 2018 will be the year of uncool
Britannia twenty years ago
Britain was riding on the crest of a
wave of cool Britpop ruled the airwaves
and the young newly elected Prime
Minister Tony Blair was pledging to
build a new Britain Britain head and
part will be unbeatable
there was cool Britannia
being cool is one of the things every we
Italians always mind the break we were
too emotional grexit comes and who over
acts the British who turns out to be
emotional the British 20 years on from
Blair's iconic address Theresa May took
to the stage at her Conservative Party
conference to deliver a less successful
speech working together we have bounced
back we've created record numbers of
jobs as the ruling Conservative Party
battles with brexit it's looking less
cruel than ever
brexit has harmed Britain's standing in
Europe in particular the Conservative
government is now seen in very negative
terms in lots of ways and the poorly
prepared brexit negotiations aren't
doing much to improve their image people
like me who spend their life learning is
sort of admiring a kind of cool way
British way of doing things the way
grexit is managed is clumsy and
amateurish as the deadline to reach a
deal approaches in 2018 things are going
to get much more fraught and all this
could have a significant impact on how
Britain is viewed by the rest of Europe
so many of the cool best ideas of the
last 25 years and probably more comes
from Britain architecture music
literature er why you want to throw it
all away
Britain's thriving creative industries
currently generate 84 billion dollars
every year that's over four percent of
GDP the UK has had this kind of cool
cachet the big warrior for these
industries that if the UK is seen as
more kind of inward-looking place that
their business will be disrupted there's
a danger London could start losing out
on the world's best creative talents
Londyn assumed this position is the
number one destination for people to go
and work from abroad
I think brexit will threaten up London
it is the most international and
exciting city in the world now don't
throw that away but the vote for brexit
in June 2016 has so far done a lot less
economic damage than many expected
consumer spending and business
investment have held up the expectation
was that the economy was going to fall
into a session almost immediately and
that didn't happen if you look at the
unemployment figures and the GDP figures
it's hard to see any brexit effective or
really the employment rate is at a
record high
and although wage growth has been poor
the jobs market has been running hot the
expectation is that that will continue
in 2018 but look at the big risk hanging
over the whole country is that the talks
break down hardline brexit ears suggest
the country has nothing to fear if the
Prime Minister walks away without a deal
yet this would bring gale warnings for
the economy you don't need to be a
financial wizard to understand the
people aware the investors are worried
and they may well take the money away
somehow from Britain so far British
businesses have been surprisingly
resilient to this uncertainty but if a
No Deal brexit looks increasingly likely
investment could suffer and things would
take a turn for the worse if a heart
breaks that starts to look likely at
some point in 2018 the economy will slow
unemployment probably will start to rise
sterling will start to fall and that
brings all sorts of unwelcome
consequences such as high inflation
financial services firms will start to
move jobs after the country
if Britain leaves without a deal it
risks becoming not only a poorer country
but a far more isolated one let's be
honest to be alone against the enemy in
1940 was heroic to be alone
among your friends in 2018 would be
absurd
you